m
le ca
et qu'une telle que c'est une banque
donnée avec pas mal d'image qui concerne
les images du département mais aussi des
partenaires privés dont nous avons
récupéré des images nature d'oiseaux des
plantes et toutes sortes de paysages
naturels et nous avons mis en valeur
avec des actuels et de collages et des
jeux numériques notamment sur tablettes
et ordinateurs
maurice maurice la réunion la réunion et
les seychelles
une fois que je fais ça tu vas devoir
restituer des images sur la carte
ensuite j'étais chez mes dents
je connais oiseaux et après après je
connais le papillon bien comme ça après
j'aimerais loyaux c'était bien oui
justement les enfants de voir qu'est ce
qui a été produit avant les beaux
dimanches des estampes les aquarelles et
le but c'est qu'ils reconnaissent les
oiseaux qui reconnaissent ces plantes
qui peuvent les situer quelques l'écart
de la réunion